what's going on guys so as you can tell
by the title of this video this is going
to be a very interesting battle now
the embargo is up we can talk about the
12th gen intel i7 12700 chipset and
we're also going to compare it against
the macbook pro m1 max
16 inch we are going to put these head
to head on an ak rendering scrubbing
playback test now let's talk about the
build we have in the pc here because we
are very excited on this this is an
aftershock build by the way again is the
12th gen intel i7 12700 chipset we've
got the geforce rtx 3070 graphics card
32 gigabytes of ddr5 ram one terabyte of
storage then
on the macbook pro we've got the 10 core
cpu 32 core gpu 64 gigabytes of unified
memory and two terabytes of storage
inside the 16 inch macbook pro this is
pretty much specced out minus the
storage on this which you can pre you
can go much higher than two terabytes
but we've got this for our review set so
we've got premiere pro loaded on both of
these computers here what we're going to
be doing is we have 8k video footage
from our nikon z9 review we haven't
checked that out click on this but wait
after this video to watch that because
this is going to be a lot more fun and
more interesting so we've got 8-bit
h.265
video we've got 10-bit h.265 video which
is end log we've also got that graded as
well so you're going to see the graphics
card kick in on the pc as well as the
macbook pro when it comes into that
graded footage coming into play so this
is gonna be a very interesting test then
afterwards we are going to do a
rendering test on both of these and then
we'll do rendering of course with final
cut pro on the m1 max just to see if
there's a big difference between that
and premiere pro versus the pc obviously
can't put final cut here on that but
we'll let the intel cool down a little
bit and let the mac just do a couple
more things you know because we can
anyway with that let's get down to
scrubbing zach you ready yeah
okay here we go we're gonna go on tier
to the pc with scrubbing ak footage
it looks like some drop frames happening
here
[Laughter]
okay
not bad some drop frames obviously not
the smooth discovering but it's much
better than previous
now we go
to the macbook pro three two one go
as you can tell no dropped frames now
i'll expand the timeline a little bit so
then you can see a little bit more in
terms of a clip instead of all these
clips put it together see a little bit
more elongated to see if you can see any
drop frames in that regard three
two one
[Laughter]
not bad right little stutters here and
there not too bad
now we're into the same thing ready
go
i think there's a clear winner on that
one i'm gonna give that to the macbook
pro there's no drop frames nothing that
was smooth as butter
that was beautiful okay so now we're
into a playback test so what we'll be
doing is playing back our 10-bit h.265
end log footage now halfway through it
is graded and that's where the graphics
card will kick in a little bit so that's
where you'll see a difference on the pc
to the mac or will we let's find out
okay three two
now as i mentioned earlier there will be
progress available on this camera soon
after launch but right now you have hlg
and end log and we're actually shooting
n log right now h265 10-bit internal at
8k
25p
this is pretty damn impressive
great mirrorless camera system
this is impressive so we're going to
grade it you're going to see the before
and after what it looks like on grade
but uh
i got to tell you that this camera is
very impressive and there goes a pelican
right there what i needed to shoot the
entire time
i missed it
but i'm showing you a log at 8k so there
you go
damn it
so as we saw right there on the playback
it was pretty choppy um even when we got
to the graded end log it was choppy as
well so what i call this smooth not
quite
but you know this is pretty good i mean
we're getting full 10-bit h.265 footage
out of this we've not done any sort of
proxy on this this is full resolution so
now we go to the macbook pro and one max
chipset and see how that handles it okay
three two
now as i mentioned earlier there will be
pro res available in this camera soon
after launch but right now you have hlg
and end log and we're actually shooting
end log right now h265 10 bit internal
at 8k
25p
this is pretty damn impressive
great mirrorless camera system
this is impressive so we're going to
grade it you're going to see the before
and after what it looks like on grade
but uh
i got to tell you man this camera is
very impressive and there goes a pelican
right there what i needed to shoot the
entire time
i missed it
but i'm showing you end log at 8k so
there you go
damn it
so i think we have a clear winner on
that one i think the macbook pro m1 max
performed beautifully with that no
dropped frames
nothing choppy
that was smooth
so we've done the scrubbing test
the macbook pro
best of the intel we've done the
playback test
the macbook pro has best of the until
thus far now we're not paid responsive
for this at all actually we didn't even
do these tests prior to this so we
really don't know what the outcome is
i'm actually impressed that it did that
well versus the intel 12 gen
i was not expecting that but now we're
gonna go to rendering we're gonna see
how these two machines handle the ak
footage we're gonna render it out in
full resolution for you
so with that let's get down to the test
let's have some fun
all right guys you ready three
two
one go
how much time you got yeah we're gonna
be here for a while huh
10 minutes i have to say i'm very
impressed with the macbook pro right now
we're eight minutes and 21 seconds
remaining
uh
on the pc where 9 minutes and 42 seconds
41 seconds remaining
all right i'm gonna grab a bite
yeah
all right jackie
you know what's interesting though
there's not even a fan
on the macbook pro
actually there's not even a fan on the
macbook pro right now so looking at this
one is about 6 minutes 30 seconds right
now it's kind of slow down a little bit
yours is seven minutes and two seconds
so you guys caught up a little bit
okay so they're almost neck and neck
right now i'm at 38 percent
you're at 37 percent actually is quite
impressive they're really neck and neck
with each other right now but anyway
while we're waiting i thought it'd be a
good time to talk to you about our
sponsor logitech here at geek culture
gaming is a way of life and we always
enjoy dishing out headshots with the
logitech g pro x super light mouse now
the lightweight wireless mouse combines
excellent performance with the classy no
frills look designed with pros and
engineered to win it offers crisp and
responsive clicks the smooth operator
even allows you to swap out the magnetic
dongle storage compartment for greater
gliding ease check out all of its other
features over at logitechg.com
okay so the macbook pro is completed to
download at nine minutes and 18 seconds
uh they're about uh we got we'll put the
exact number right down below the screen
here and we've got 30 seconds remaining
and we're at 10 minutes
and 4 seconds right now and it's still
going so
i mean obviously the macbook pro has won
this challenge but by how much
this is going to uh very very
interesting to see how this uh plays out
wow by over a minute
by over a minute the macbook pros okay
so the pc finished in 10 minutes and 41
seconds
and the macbook pro m1 max finished in 9
minutes and 18 seconds thereabouts we're
running it down but
that's the difference between these two
uh machines
but
there's something i didn't tell you
it's not been plugged in the entire time
and in terms of heat
it's just slightly warm
that's impressive
this
is extremely impressive
i've never seen a laptop do something
like this before
at least
an apple laptop for that matter so as we
saw from the h.264 obviously macbook pro
did best the intel chipset however now
we're going to do it in pro res
through premiere pro
so we'll see how well both these
machines handle that three
two
one go
uh seems the pc is a little bit slower
right now
now of course
i think apple's
whole system is really built around
prores for optimizing prores i mean
final cut just chews through prores it's
nothing to the to it you know but this
is very impressive look at the bar it's
just moving along
[Music]
dude this is chugging through i mean
obviously slow way slower than final cut
final coat was done one minute 17
seconds all right welcome to a special
segment where we ask facts about bobby
so um what's your zodiac sign scorpio
how do you feel right now
tired what's your favorite movie
godfather one and two how tall are you
one point eight three
oh you didn't meet us man okay wow oh
matrix is fun hey i've been in singapore
for 14 years i've converted to meters
name three things that you love
my dog
my partner and my mom
name three things that upset you three
things that upset me
slow computers
[Laughter]
uh telemarketing calls coming in and
that's pretty much it i don't have three
things just two who's your favorite
celebrity crush
depends
depends right now
i love margot robbie i love mardu robbie
all right
what is your favorite perfume
i don't wear perfume i'm a guy
okay what's your favorite cologne
i shouldn't have one
just wear the odor most of the time some
sponsors anyone out there
is there anything you wanted to do in
your youth that you still haven't done
many many things i would love to travel
the world more
i would have loved to
we're almost at 93 percent there right
come on i don't know i don't mean
there's so many things you kind of like
we look back i think i'm more traveling
i think traveling would have been the
big thing for me and that's it all right
and 96
wow 74 and ninety seven percent
okay
have a final no i can't even beat this
inside it's no it's too far off already
and done
five sixteen
i mean honestly this is just impressive
dude the macbook pro is done at five
minutes is 17 seconds and the pc is
still going you got a you've done you've
run 85 percent of it at five minutes and
59 seconds i mean honestly i think this
chipset's obviously really good but this
goes to show how good the architecture
is in the m1 max chipsets i think from
apple this is warm but it's not hot
this is not even close to the heat that
i would feel on the 16 inch macbook pro
from 2019.
that fan
by
from all the testing we've done
it would have sounded like an air
conditioning unit it was so loud
okay
about a little over two minutes more
on the pc versus
the macbook pro
impressive now
what we're gonna do is
we're gonna run pro res
off a final cut
on the macbook pro and one max and see
how fast that is
let's do it right now just to give you a
heads up on this the macbook pro has
been unplugged this entire time
now usually laptops perform better when
they're plugged in versus unplugged
apple has touted that no it performs the
same so what we wanted to do is run all
these benchmark tests
without
a power source into it
on top of that there are apps that are
running in the background of this as
well
so
now we're going to test to see how fast
prores rendering is
on final cut
10.6
let's do this
go
percentage raw
this is insane
it's almost like a percentage a second
[Music]
it's almost done
it's at 85 percent
okay wow okay okay
that is
that's insane that's i mean
i personally never see numbers like that
and i don't own a mac pro so
you know for those of you who do own
those you probably have seen this but i
have not
um i've been using an m1 imac as you
guys saw in my first impressions uh
video as a comparison
i mean that that to me was fast
this is on another level
so
anyway i don't know what else to say i'm
kind of shocked all right guys so that's
our uh fun little test here at the geek
culture studios with these uh 12th
generation intel i7 12700 chipset of
course we had the uh geforce rtx uh 3070
uh gpu then of course we've got 32
gigabytes of ddr5 ram one terabyte of
storage in the after shot computer and
this 16 inch macbook pro is a 10 core
cpu 32 core gpu 64 gigabytes of unified
memory and two terabytes of storage
so two very powerful machines for
anybody out there
how do they perform
man this mac is good
anyway
hope you guys enjoyed that subscribe and
like this video helps us out a lot take
care stay safe and we will see you in
the next one take care